[Music]
hello and welcome back to the road to
2000 as always my name is Caleb envy and
I will be your driver on this journey
today I wanted to take a look at another
tournament going on currently in the
chess world
we've still got tons and tons of these
world-class online events going on with
all the players that you would expect
the one going on right now of course is
the chest bull masters tournament and
they actually just wrapped up the
preliminary stage of the events
yesterday I believe now the way the
preliminary stage worked is there were
two groups of players there were six
players in Group A six players in Group
B and then the top four players from
each group moved on to the quote-unquote
playoffs so on the final day there were
actually multiple players in situations
where they absolutely had to win their
game so I wanted to look at two of the
notable ones that is a game between
akaru
and Daniel dubov and a game between
grish ik and Hari Krishna and I wanted
to see how these players actually chose
to play their games when they knew they
were under this much pressure where they
absolutely had to win their games to
advance so let's jump into it here
in Game one I wanted to look at Hikaru
against dubov because this is really
sort of the the main event of the final
day Hikaru was I believe on four points
dubov was on five points and with Abe
just a draw
I believe dubov would have secured his
place in these playoff matches so dubov
has the black pieces needs only a draw
against Hikaru Hikaru absolutely must
win if he is going to advance so how do
they play this game well the cargo
chooses one efore and this is no
surprise a lot of the time when somebody
has the white pieces and they absolutely
must win efore is sort of the go-to
that's not to say you can't score ones
but d4 c4 or even Knight f3
but efore is sort of the default
fallback to try and actually prove an
advantage with white and then do Bop
interestingly goes with c5 and this is a
decision that could very easily be
criticized if you are a fan of dubov
because dubov chooses a very combative
line that you would expect if he was
playing black in his own must-win
situation or something like this when he
only needs a draw
you might as a do buffin have wanted to
see something like e5 you know the
Petroff the berlin or something like
this but no he goes with c5 and I'm
actually gonna defend this decision by
dubov even though it didn't work out for
him here today when you are you know the
2700 level player that that dubov is
against your biggest rivals in rapid
chess it's more important for you I
think to get a position that you're
familiar with and comfortable with more
than getting sort of this dead drawn
position that you would want in a in a
must or in a draw when a in a situation
where a draw is enough I don't know if
there's a term for that one it wasn't
necessarily a must draw but he needed at
least a draw to secure his place so it's
more important I think to get a position
you're familiar with as I said then it
is to get a position that's that's sort
of dead and dubov has been playing this
this line I think quite regularly for
some time now in the game and continued
Knight f3 knight c6 Knight c3 and g6 so
we have of course the accelerated dragon
appearing on the board after d4 see d4
Knight takes d4 Bishop g7 and Bishop e3
so of course the dragon is with d6
included the accelerated dragon is where
black delay is playing d6 in an effort
to play d5 in one fell swoop this is
sort of the idea of the accelerated
dragon now
dubov continues with Knight f6 which is
by far the main move we have Bishop c4
by white which is sensible playing to
control the d5 squit the square excuse
me we have castles by black we
there should be three the main line by
white and then dubov pulls out this move
when she's actually played before and is
quite an interesting one even though it
is not the most common here dubov plays
the move rook to e8 and this rook e8
move is definitely a sideline in this
dragon position quite often players will
transpose to the normal dragon with d6
here allowing f3 when you go into quite
often some Yugoslavia tax I believe
there's also of course they move a5
which is sort of the second option for
black playing on the Kings side here or
the Queen side here but this mover ki8
has definitely been tested for some time
now and if I'm not mistaken I believe
you know I'm I'm no expert
dragon player but I'll leave the point
of this rook e8 move is that after f3
it's actually quite possible to play d5
in that one fell swoop as black had
always intended and after d5 you go down
a very forcing line
he takes d5 Knight b4 hits this pawn
Knight d2 e 2 is the choice to defend it
then e 6 d6 is quite common for right
here although here the variations do
start to branch and dubov actually has a
game that he drew against Fabiana cara
wanna that went d6 Knight bd5 and after
regaining the pawn dubov did manage to
draw this one I think without too much
controversy in this game however this is
not what we saw in this game against
karu rather than go for this f3 business
this is sort of probably what do love
was hoping for this is what he was more
familiar with Hikari Oh actually comes
up with a bit of a novelty here and I've
said before this is the danger that you
run into at these top levels when you do
consistently play the same things over
and over again it's a problem Hikaru
himself had run into by playing the same
qgd line over and over again when these
top players know what to expect from you
they can very very much do
some serious homework and surprised you
a bit with a move he may have not
analyzed as thoroughly as needed and so
here
the Carter pulls out a big novelty with
the move f4 and undoubtably I think
dubov had probably looked at this move
at some point in his life even though
it's never played never been played this
is definitely one of those natural moves
that you should check if you're at the
level of Dan'l dubov in the game he
chose the move d6 which i think is quite
natural and now Hikaru follows up with
Queen f3 and the point of whites placed
so far is that he has not yet committed
this King to either side of the board
he's sort of waiting to do this until
black either starts wasting Tempe with
more waiting moves or until he commits
to to a more serious option for example
if dubov ever tries to play the move d5
well in this case the move e5 is going
to be quite strong and the point is now
we have this G 1 square for the bishop
to defend our knight now imagine instead
if white castled here and the move d5
came on the board now e5 Knight g4 all
of a sudden this is significantly more
awkward for white to deal with the g1
score not available to the bishop that's
not even to say that's a d5 would be the
best move in fact perhaps Knight g4
immediately what would even be good also
instead of queen of three if castles or
after Queen f3 if the same idea Knight
g4 yes this G 1 square is available but
even this is not necessarily the best
that white can do even the move Knight
takes c6 and B c6 Bishop back to D 2 is
totally playable and black is just left
in this sort of limbo where he doesn't
want to commit to too much too early on
another sort of useful move that you
would expect from black is occasionally
the idea to play this movie 6 however
the second the e6 lens on the board this
is where Hikaru is no longer castling
kingside
Stud has the opportunity to Castle
queenside thereby getting his King out
of the center and immediately pressuring
this d6 pawn all in one turn and this is
sort of the power of the move order that
karo has chosen here by delaying this
idea of castling the king he gives
himself very useful options to cancel
either Queen side or Kings side
depending on blacks choices now in my
opinion sort of the default in this
position is actually to Castle kingside
with the White King and so after we see
the move Bishop d7 by black that's
exactly what akaru does he castles kings
side and now sort of the point I think
that an karo has made is that if he had
castled rather than play Queen of three
rather than play the move f4 the point
he's trying to make is that black would
be making much more useful moves than
Bishop d7 with this tempo specifically
this moved Knight g4 and so by delaying
this castling he's kind of baited dubov
into playing the move Bishop d7 which I
mean in its own right is not a bad move
it's sort of a waiting move but on the
other hands it's not the most useful
move plat could have made so in a sense
black is sort of losing tempo by playing
this move Bishop d7 here and in karo he
uses this extra tempo to sort of launch
an even more powerful attack than you
would expect in the dragon so white
castles King side immediately black
plays Knight g4 and now we have Knight
takes c6 b takes c6 and Bishop d2 so
this is still well within what we would
expect kind of so far from from this
game
black immediately after white goes like
castles does go in for this Knight g4
line forcing this Bishop back to e2 and
now that white has castled and he's
gotten this Knight out of the way he is
more comfortable playing this move d5
now for Ricardo he does have various
options here one choice is to capture
this pawn he takes d5 but the issue is
no matter how can you take this pawn
back you're always going to have some
slight awkwardness with this bishop
targeting this b2 pond for example if
you take with the knight immediately
Bishop takes b2 is definitely a move you
you have to look out for have to
consider so it's not really a true pawn
sacrifice and many of the cases for for
black I suppose in this case it is a bit
more of a serious pawn sacrifice but I
don't think black is out all unhappy
after xc8 targeting this knight on c3
targeting this pawn on b2 definitely a
lot of compensation there so that's one
choice for your cardio but I don't think
he liked that one quite as much movie 5
is also a choice for akaru but I sort of
think this is what do Bob was hoping for
you can imagine that game can continue
with something like Queen b6 check king
h1 and I move like h5 and now do Bob is
sort of trying to consolidate and defend
these light squares with a move like 9
h6 - to follow it's not to say this
isn't still a very decent position for
white you can start playing on the Queen
side with ideas of 9 a 4 and knights e5
but black is at least not getting rolled
over on the Kings side however Fabiana
or in this case akaru not Fabiano sort
of chose door number 3 so who in the
chat room can guess the move that Hakkar
you played sort of the third candidate
move that you should consider in this
position who thinks they have it
so yet the chatroom is accurate here the
move is going to be F 5 in this case H 3
is actually also a very good move worth
considering but in this case I do think
let's let's stick with f5 h 3 you know
just sort of a tempo move to get rid of
this thing before making any decisions
so f5 in this case was played in the
game and I think already from from what
I can tell
dubov has a rather uncomfortable
position right out of the gate here
perhaps this was sort of his last chance
to kind of recover you could have played
the move G takes f 5 and after a takes
at 5 Knight back to f6 and I still don't
like this position for black but with
this knight on f6 black is guarding most
of these key squares he is going to come
under some fire on the G file and this
epon is going to be slightly
uncomfortable but you can imagine after
let's say some solid improving move by
white the movie six by black could be
coming and after it takes c6 black is
sort of trying to survive by breaking
out along this efile is he going to
succeed it's still kind of unclear to me
and it would require a lot more analysis
than I've done to tell you the objective
truth of that position but I sort of
think this was do Bob kind of last try
to stay in the game here after f5
understandably dubov goes Knight to e5
but this is just sort of the incorrect
defensive setup for black here and the
reason for that is this f6 square is
going to be too critical in this
position it's the f6 square where white
does end up breaking through and it's
the square that is causing the problems
for black so Knight to e5 of course we
don't want to move this Queen over to g3
or h3 we want to move it back to f2
because f6 is now sort of our target we
want to continue attacking the square in
the game dubov plays a6 and this sort of
just immediately loses the game to the
move f6 now after Knight g4 like sort of
clever move for King Queen and pawn at
first glance
unfortunately the move Queen f3 is just
going to be devastating
in in this case the idea being if you do
capture on f6 as you want to the move e5
is is quite nasty and all of a sudden
the battery along the F file is coming
through plague could continue 94 and
Knight takes e4 D takes c4 Queen f7
check King h8 and this is a position
that dubov could try to play obviously
this one is going to be quite good for
white and after simply Queen f4 c5 Queen
takes e4 nakamura would have just
collected an extra pawn with a safer
King and control over the f7 square
really devastating stuff for dubov here
in the game he tried the move Queen
takes f6 but of course this just goes
down a piece after Queen g4 check
Quinton Queen D or sorry Queen takes g4
Queen d4 check Eric F - f5 Queen f3 it
takes on e4 and well
dubov did get the strong center he's
actually losing a second piece in this
case III would regain one of the pieces
but it's only one of the pieces and so
eventually Nakamura does go on to win
this game Queen takes c6 Eric over to f8
challenging this rook it should be one
Queen e3 and at the end of the night
takes d5 Queen e2 and Queen B 5 check
was all do Bob needed to see before
throwing in the towel and resigning here
25 check of course a very nasty move
diverting this bishop away from the pin
so white can recapture the Queen on e 2
so the moral of this game is is
basically don't fall into Nakamura's
prep because nakamora had some very very
good prep here and this is I believe
posing some very serious problems to
this entire idea of rook e8 it's not to
say that there isn't a way for black to
still equalize against this move rook e8
but I spent some serious time looking
around and I'm not so sure that I found
the the way to equalize after this idea
f4 and Queen f3 pretty nasty stuff
perhaps the best line that I had found
was in fact to play this move Knight g4
and play my continued Knight takes c6 v
takes c6 ship d2 and then believe it or
not the move Knight f6 is actually well
worth considering
the point being now if you do Castle
kingside
we can get something similar to what
we've already seen after the move
d5 now unfortunately for white the move
f5 is going to come with a lot less much
less gusto after D takes e4 and they
take c4 and Bishop takes f5 so I think
bringing this knight back to f6 is
actually a very serious consideration
now the move D or the move e5 would
still be playable and perhaps this is
what white should be going for but I
think after ninety seven black might be
might be holding on here immediately the
move east six isn't going to be good
enough you can simply capture this and
take back control of the e5 square and
if a six immediately doesn't work then
sort of this entire attack on the Kings
side is beginning to slow down a bit for
whites so this is the best I could find
for black is simply going Knight g4 and
after they exchanged repeating moves
with with Knight f6 maybe the move h3 is
good enough for white just to stop
Knight g4 and still even further
delaying castling and now the move d5
would in fact be met with E 5 and after
Queen side castles this stuff with g4
and f5 is coming quite quickly but it's
still unclear to me what's going on
exactly in this position and I'll leave
that to do buff and do buffs team to
figure out I'm sure next time this gets
played over the board we will see a
little bit more astute defense from the
black side with that in mind very
excellent game from Nakamura and this is
just what you have to do if you are in a
must-win situation naka ready to risk it
all exposing you know his super secret
rook e8 prep and going for an immediate
King side attack not afraid to increase
the tension in the position and get
something super complex that's what you
have to do in a must-win situation
moving along more bad news for dubov
even though he lost
this game against Takara Nakamura if in
this second game
Alexander Grisham had not defeated
pintado Harry Krishna then dubov would
still be in the playoffs but
unfortunately for dubov Grichuk wins
this game as well bringing him into a
tie it with both akaru and dubov all on
five points and do about with the worst
tiebreaks did end up not qualifying so
that being said Grichuk himself was also
in a must-win situation here and I
wanted to examine how he did it as well
so in this game we did see the move d4
as I've said before usually the fall
backs when they're in a must-win
situation not to say you can't score
ones with d4 and c4 either in this
particular game alright question one
goes for Knight f6 c4 e6 and Knight f3
and now c5 and I think this is partially
down to the tournament and that's heart
Krishna is was having he had some very
unfortunate losses early on and at this
point I think he was just too far out of
the leaders in order to catch up in
qualify for the playoffs I've got to
stop wearing this jacket during this
classes so he chose a more fun opening
than good opening in the benoni
although the fun part is questionable d5
is the move played by Kirk and once
again this is what you have to do in a
must-win situation you have to play the
most contesting lines have to go for as
much as you possibly can out of the
opening to get a position that could
result in a win in this game we saw a
takes d5 C takes D 5 and then Hari
Krishna does something very interesting
that I've actually seen before not from
any of the top grandmasters but instead
from my old teammate on the U of I chess
team and that thing that he does is he
just doesn't play d6 for quite a few
moves and me being the fool that I am
always tried to like
find some way to punish my opponent for
not playing d6 in this game though
you'll see the correct approach by
Grichuk which is just saying why are you
doing this and going about your business
developing normally
so hard crushed nut plays g6 rather than
d6 and knocked Knight c3 rather than d6
our Krishna plays Bishop g7 and now
after efore rather than d6 hari krishna
castles and now after Bishop d3 rather
than d6 alright Krishna plays the move
rook e8 and then white simply castled in
this case and our Christian have finally
relented saying okay okay fine I will
play the move d6 and I'm not sure what
advantage Hari Krishna was hoping to
attain by delaying this move perhaps he
was trying to avoid some of the more
annoying lines involving Bishop f4 and
going after this pawn immediately but
whatever his reasons maybe he plays d6
now and we are very much back into a
normal-looking position after d6 the
only slightly strange thing is that
black has played rook e8 very very early
on rather than play move like a6 going
for p5 I move like that be g7 or move
like Bishop g4 and because of that I
think blacks options are quite limited
here because black delayed playing d6
for so long
Bishop g4 is no longer available to him
and to ensure this in Grichuk actually
plays the move h3 and I think this is a
great idea by grishnack just keeping
this Bishop out of g4 now forever and
this move also steers the the game back
into very very normal territory this is
just a well known position now in the
benoni and how krishna goes for a line
which for a lack of a better word I
think just loses by force and in Chris
Rick found the way to punish this in
this game
Hare Krishna plays the move c4 and
grishnack plays the most forcing line
the line with Bishop c2 is definitely
playable and this has been played before
well over a hundred times actually but
this is sort of giving giving black what
he wants he wants to play b5 here
tempting you into accepting this pawn
when they take c4 would follow on the
board and things become a little bit
more open a little bit more free rather
than that though Grichuk just captures
in this pawn on c4 and now black is sort
of forced to capture on e4 this was the
point of his play now after Knight takes
e4 we have rook takes e4 and suddenly
the move from Bishop d3 appears on the
board and it's not so clear where this
rook is actually going now generally the
move Bishop g5 has actually been played
a bit more often here and after Bishop
f6 then Bishop d3 but this doesn't allow
stuff like Queen of fate to actually
come on the board so Grichuk plays
Bishop d3 first trying to perhaps avoid
an option like Queen f8 rook e8 is just
the best score on the board for this
rook and now after Bishop g5 we do see
Bishop f6
Grizzard continues with the move Queen
a4 which sort of counters one threat
with another now after Bishop takes e5
which is played in the game we have
Knight takes g5 and this is just a very
tough position now for for black perhaps
the best try is to just continue
development with a move like ninety
seven you're gonna get met with a move
like ninety four and all of a sudden
it's very very difficult to meet this
threat you don't really want to be
playing Knight c5 here as already there
is a second threat in the position so
you're more than a little stuck here
think you have to play a move like
rookie five and after rook e1 this is
like I said going to be rather
uncomfortable for for black here now in
the game
rookie five was played immediately and I
would like to invite you guys at home to
find the winning sequence here for
Alexander district that he did find in
the game there's only one line that does
it but grishnack managed to to find it
what do you guys think
wait to move and win
there's a couple suggestions rook a to
e1 has been suggested to move Queen f4
has been suggested this move is is
pretty interesting but I think it does
in fact fail to not Bishop rook takes g5
not even Queen takes g5 which would
allow the move f4 but rather the move
Bishop d7 when all of a sudden your
Queens attacked the e8 square is
defended and you might be facing or it
takes g5 next so interesting move
they're not quite it the move Queen up
for does in fact actually just allow the
capture of this Knight unfortunately so
you have to do a little bit better than
that guys you got it yeah Beltran has it
see I got August has it or ghost a I
don't know how to say things and it's
the move f4 and so why does this move
actually win well after the move or it
takes d5 which is more or less forced by
black if you just kind of retreat you're
asking for the move f5 to come on the
board which is going to be devastating
with all files sort of opening up so you
have to kind of take keep an eye on this
f5 square and now unfortunately the move
played in the game
Queen c4 is just more or less game over
there's nothing you can really do here
if you play the move Bishop e6 it's just
going to get captured and then Bishop e4
and you are getting criss-crossed all
over the chessboard on the white squares
after this so in the game harikrishna
plays rook takes g5 but after F takes G
5 and Bishop e6 the move Queen 4 comes
on the board knight c6 and this is sort
of just a dead loss position now for
Hari Krishna and that being said there
is still a technical task to be
completed here for Grichuk which he does
very very well he starts with the move
rook f2 just guarding all these squares
along the second-ranked and preparing to
bring this rook over to f1 if necessary
also actually preparing to tuck this
bishop away back on f1 and it's this
move that is actually played in the game
after 95 and this is sort of really
commendable
Grichuk if you're if you find yourself
in sort of a rapid game or a little bit
low on time then priority number one if
you are sort of in a winning position up
material it's always going to be to
protect the king and that's exactly what
grocery does with rack up to in Bishop
f1 he says I'm defending all of these
squares do what you like elsewhere on
the board I'm making sure my king is
safe first and foremost I'm not going to
blunder anything on this side of the
board and then I will slowly but surely
convert my advantage the move Queen b6
comes on the board pinning their worth
to the king and so of course grocery
plays the move king h2 saying yes thank
you for trying but I'm not going to
blend or anything on this side of the
board I'm making sure my king is safe
rook c8 now comes on the board and
grizzard continues very simply just
limiting the activity of his opponent's
pieces he notices that this square is
definitely something black would like to
use dropping a bishop here dropping a
knight here and so the move b3 comes on
the board saying no you may not have
that c4 square as well and it's this
limiting play that really ensures
nothing can go wrong here for white the
move rook c3 is allowed but this is sort
of an empty threat with all these
squares being fairly well covered and
now just rook d1 by white activating his
final piece putting pressure on the d6
pawn Queen c7 was played in the game and
now King Ji Won was Critics Choice sort
of dropping the King back now that this
pin is no longer a concern the move a5
comes on the board
Queen d4 puts even more pressure onto
this guy and now d5 was sort of the the
breaking point for Hari Krishna in fact
there is another winning tactic here for
white which I would like to invite you
guys at home to try and find because
winning tactics ro is fun too to try and
find Greg did not actually find it in
the game not that it mattered too much
cursory just sort of continued playing
his very natural chess but wait to move
and win even more here what can you play
to pick up this d5 pawn does anybody in
the chat see it
August like the month got it instead of
rook takes d5 why not rookie three
threatening the bishop I can back up and
take a look at that we will continue on
to the end first though
alright nobody I think has the tactic
just yet I'm just going to show it
because it's none of the utmost
importance here it is the very very
clever move Bishop c4 interfering with
Queen and rook and adding another
attacker to the d5 of course especially
cannot be captured or else Queen takes
c3 will come on the board and so Ritchie
three or something
and after the d5 pawn falls it really is
just game over
instead this was missed in the move
Queen at four was played which is
totally fine and now after b6 the move
rook e1 is sort of devastating for black
ninety seven and one last time white to
move and win here go ahead pause your
videos if you want to try to find it
yourself if not here it is rook takes c6
is the sort of last hurrah and by
White's just checkmating the black King
in very very short order if Queen takes
that fork
rikiei check and where it takes up four
if F takes c6 Queen f7 check King h8 and
not Queen f8 check but Queenie a check
and rook f7 is another checkmate the
rook takes c6 is a game under there and
harder Krishna resigns and with it so do
so go also goes Daniel do Bob's chances
of advancing to the playoffs with this
win by Grichuk unfortunate for dubov but
a well-played game to be sure and by
Alexander Grichuk so these were two
games where the players were in must-win
situations with the white pieces and
this is exactly what you would expect to
see from such high level players they
came with their best games under
pressure using the most combative
openings that they could find and really
tried to take it to their opponents and
in this case they both succeeded
advancing on now unfortunately that was
all the must-win games
I could find from the chest bowl masters
so I just wanted to move on to a couple
more games that I just really enjoyed
from the same tournament the chasuble
masters so let's move on to a game by
Fabiano kara wanna against Yan an
opponent she now while this technically
may not be a must-win game in hindsight
if the car if Fabi didn't win this game
he would not have advanced the playoffs
I think so in hindsight he it was very
very important than he won the game
one could say he had to win the game it
was a must win game see all right so
let's take a look in this game we
complete our trifecta of wide openings
not efore not d4 but now c4 and in this
game Yan responds with Knight f6 Knight
c3 we have E 5 g3 and d5 and this is
sort of the most combative try by black
in this case not meeting the most
complex try going for a complicated
position rather this is black trying to
equalize sort of right out of the gate
by playing the most strictly principled
moves right out of the opening as
possible
lee v seizing the center white plates to
move g3 not attacking the center so d5
also seizing the center and so what this
says is basically you have to prove
something concrete with white or else
I'm going to be totally totally equal
with no issues at all so in the game C
takes d5 is the main move Knight takes
d5 and a Bishop g2 we have nitin back to
b6 this is all very mainline stuff and
now d3 by Tommy is a little bit less
common than Knight f3 but it does come
with a very very sneaky idea actually by
delaying Knight f3
Fabiano is sort of hinting and that if
you ever play this move knight c6 I
might be so inclined as to capture this
Bishop fracturing your pawns and playing
this sort of endgame position and this
is something that has actually been
tried before by high level players but
in this game yon had no interest in
going for things like that playing
Bishop e7 instead Bishop e3 by a funny
sort of continues this sod where if you
play knight c6 I might just capture it
you never know but just castles by yon
and
even rooks see one still trying to tempt
black into playing the move knight c6
when I still might capture it with my
bishop but instead riki eights and now
finally we do see Knight f3 by white
sort of relenting saying okay fine if
you're gonna play 96.9 c6 and yon
happily does now simply castles by
whites we have Bishop f8 by black and
Bishop g5 by Fabi is an attempt to just
force a little bit of awkwardness
now yon plays a very very sort of
strange-looking move rather than what
may be quite simply the most natural
move in the position of f6 kicking this
bishop away following it up with Bishop
e6 when you have a very solid structure
on the Kings side with a perfect little
home for the bishop yon plays the very
non-standard looking move Queen d7 as to
why yon played this I'm not so sure why
he didn't want to play these f6 lines
maybe he just wanted to keep his pawns
absolutely where they are on the Kings
side not admitting any weaknesses but
basically the point is this isn't a bad
move so so why not play it why isn't the
why isn't it a bad move blocking in the
bishop well because it's not all that
important for the moment white is going
to move this bishop again and black is
going to move this Queen again so is it
really a loss of tempo if both sides are
losing the tempo I'm not so sure anyways
in the game a3 was played h6 was played
kicking this Bishop back and then this
Queen actually does come back to d8 and
yon has actually had this exact position
with the white side before so perhaps
this is where he got this Queen d7 Queen
d8 idea from now in this game the move
Knight e4 was played which actually does
follow Yuans game from 2017 then a5 and
now
Fabi does deviate from the game that Yan
had in Yuans game he actually chose the
move Bishop e3 in fabi's game we instead
see the move Knight c5 and so what do we
have in this middle game position
here well Yan has achieved something by
getting to moved a five in with a five
he's preventing white from seizing all
of this queenside space with the move b4
Yan has also achieved something by
getting the move d5 through with d5 on
the board trading off the C pawn for the
D pawn he does have a lot of space for
his pieces including a wide open
diagonal one for this bishop and two for
this bishop which is something that can
only be achieved by moving this pawn at
least two squares opening up both
diagonals so these are things that Yan
has achieved however is yan totally
equalized here this is sort of a
question that is not quite as easy to
answer while the position may be equal I
would venture to say that black actually
has a lot more practical problems here
than white does white can sort of make
more comfortable moves moves like Queen
c2 moves like Europe d1 moves like
Bishop back to e3 even if necessary and
in the meanwhile it's sort of less easy
to understand how black is actually
going to finish development of this
Bishop on c8 also not as easy to
understand what exactly this Knight is
doing on b6 and what this rook is doing
on a ace so these are sort of the last
remaining problems for black the reason
it's so difficult to see what's going to
happen to these pieces is because as
always whenever white theme keto is thus
LightSquared Bishop it can easily turn
into a monster piece and that's what
it's sort of threatening to do here with
all this pressure on the light squares
along this long diagonal so is yan doing
fine here yes probably but practically
he has a ways to go before he can sort
of just sit comfortably in this game the
move a4 was played forever sort of
locking down ideas of b4 with the move a
takes P 3 in the game Queen c2 by favi
is just a natural and developing
improving move and then we see yan sort
of play this move rook i7 which looks
very unnatural
perhaps is an indication of the
practical problems that plaque is facing
here and that being said things
definitely have not gone wrong yet for
young and we do see the move rook F to e
1 by Fabi now in this exact position yon
makes a very committal decision and this
is why I think blacks position was
actually perhaps practically not doing
as well as one might think just by
looking at the sort of more objective
computer analysis for example if yawn
plays a move like Bishop e7 just sort of
passing the time it's not so clear what
white is going to be doing it's sort of
a game of patience here because if white
is the one to kind of go crazy first and
play a move like efore well now he's
never going to get control of the d4
square back it plays a move like III
this is potentially possible but for the
moment there are immediate tactical
issues with it by hanging the d3 pawn
and if you try to prepare some of these
ideas something like this should be one
well then it's Bishop f1 rather then
you're sort of just making your own
piece worse so becomes this game where
both players are going to try and prove
that's you know their position is
improved to the max and there's not much
else to do for example this is well in a
very unusual way for a game to develop
it's actually not the most ridiculous
here because sort of whoever blinks
first might actually be gaming up a
large portion of the Equality might be
ending up in a worse position in this
case yan is the one who sort of flinched
first not playing these strange-looking
moves like Bishop e7 or wrote back to a8
as the engine suggests quite
understandably by the way instead he
plays the move 94 which is a concrete
attempt not only to solve all of his
problems but in fact in attempts to say
that white is the one with more issues
here after the move Knight takes d4 and
a takes d4 you can very easily imagine a
world where this e to pawn just ends up
being a weak backwards pawn sort of
forever
with no no sign of life now
unfortunately after 94 net 64 and eat XD
for Bobby is immediately able to sort of
strike back and seize the initiative
so rather than even entertain these
thoughts of this pawn not being able to
move anywhere
Bobby immediately plays the movie for
now this central pawn majority was scary
enough for Yan to snatch this pawn off
the board
now after Bishop takes III we do see the
move c6 so this is blacks attempt to
just solve his problems immediately he
gets rid of the knight on c6 gets rid of
the pawn on e4 and plays the move c6 and
now after c6 he's trying to claim that
the move Bishop f5 or Bishop e6 even
will be comfortable equality for him
finishing his development
unfortunately that is just not the case
here and the reason that isn't the case
is because he's he's given up quite a
number of squares in exchange for this
idea namely he's given up the d4 square
he's given up the e4 square and white is
now about to make use of all of these
things 94 comes on the board and all of
a sudden this bishop springs to life as
as well with c6 also notably giving up
the b6 square now just for example if a
move like rook a eights you're sort of
really asking for trouble here this is
in fact a losing move due to Bishop
takes b6 Queen takes b6 negative six
check and this is just game over so
natural moves like that to unpin don't
quite work the move rook a6 is actually
potentially playable but Yohn wanted
none of this instead just developing
with the move Bishop e6 now however you
know once the floodgates have sort of
been opened there's no going back and
closing them and Fabi continues quite
naturally with the move Bishop c5
removing this defender of all the
weakened dark squares in the black camp
this is an idea that you'll see when
there is a thean keto bishop of course
black would love to trade off these
light square Bishop s' to further weaken
light squares in the white camp but the
idea holds true for weak squares
anywhere on the board this Bishop is
being very very useful guarding the weak
in dark squares made by putting these
pawns on light squares so if white
manages to get rid of it then those dark
squares are going to be even more
weakened rook e8 played in the game
Bishop takes that fate Erik takes f8 and
now Knight c5 and there's simply nothing
to test this Knight anymore in the game
yan felt the need to come all the way
back to c8 and it's quite clear that
while he thought he was able to solve
his problems with the move c6 his
problems have definitely persisted with
this Bishop having to come back and once
again there are three pieces in the
black camp that just looked totally
dominated by the way pieces rookie four
on the board for Fabi is now immediately
sort of just gaining upon Rick e8 was
played rook CDE one was fabi's choice
maintaining control the e-file or it
takes c4 or it takes c4 Recces five hits
this Knight and rather than try to cash
in with a move like Knight 8th for this
would actually fall victim to the move
and Bishop f5 Fabi just maintains the
balance and plays the move Age 3 and
this is is sort of nasty here now Bishop
a5 still is not playable due to the
night takes p7 tactic and black is just
totally unable to move he's he's quite
frozen in this case perhaps his best try
it was playing the move Knight d7 just
giving up on this pawn on a 4 but in
fact this is just a clean pawn down for
black and this is going to be a very
tough endgame to try to hold instead he
tried to move King f8
but now the move d4 comes on the board
another square given up by these this
force sequence and that black went in
for and after Rick a8 rook back to e1
this is a position that Fabiano Cara
Juana is going to win a lot of the time
if you give it to them just more central
space more active pieces anywhere on the
board control of the only open file
threats of Queen age 7 it's just
devastating
I mentioned cringe seven it's quite
relevant you cannot capture this pawn
due to this tactic if g6 just Queen
takes h6 check and rook e8 check - to
follow so d4 is untouchable Yan chose g6
to defend and now simply Queen d2 if I
could play it attacks h6 defense d4 King
g7 now Queen up to f4 Knight back to d7
and now 90 for Fabi definitely not
interested in trading off any of these
passive black pieces for the active
white pieces
rook a5 was Yuans choice but
unfortunately for him this goes into a
forced losing sequence so 96 hits the f7
pawn Knight f6 is Yuans choice to defend
and now once again chatroom white to
move and win see if you can find the
victory here Voltron's says why do these
guys draw all the time except when dubov
needs them to draw that's that's a fair
point that's a fair point I think
there's a lot of dubov fans out there
myself included who were very sad to see
him not getting into the not getting
into the playoffs but that's the way the
the cards fell this time
and everybody has the answer of course I
sort of hinted at it with this f7 pawn
it's the devastating move rook e8 this
move dere is black to take with the
night when this is simply going to be an
unstoppable mate threat the Queen takes
d4 the very curious move Knight f6 is
actually going to be unstoppable mate on
either of these squares and so you will
have to give up this Queen and that will
be the match in the game yan tried Queen
d7 just going down the full Bishop
but of course down a full Bishop is
going to be enough and g5 removes the
defender of this Knight but Queen d2 is
a nice tempo move hitting the rook rook
a6 Queen B for now reestablishes the
connection to the knight c5 d c5 and
this Knight is staying there forever
rook takes d6 does regain the piece but
by this point
Fabi is up technically only two pawns
but these are very very serious pawns
that Fabio's up and this is a very easy
technically winning endgame yan tries to
create some kerfuffle around the White
King but none of a five he's having none
of it he just starts pushing these guys
up the board d7 gets the Queen's off the
board and now up two pawns is simple
enough for Fabi pushing all the way to
victory here and so this was a nice win
by Bobby karamaneh not necessarily a
must-win situation as the first two were
but I very much enjoyed this game and
now as we have 10 minutes I did want to
cheat a little bit on the topic of
tonight's lecture not that I've you know
I might have already cheated enough by
including non must-win games but earlier
in this game I was watching the live
broadcast and yessir Sarah want a
commentator of the game mentioned a game
that he had against me hail tall that
actually went with tall going Knight d4
white capturing on
before as we saw in this game Edie for
and the difference in that game is white
did not immediately get this eform move
in and in that game
yessir was like was saying how he was
under so much pressure and how towel had
obviously outplayed him and then tile
offered him a draw the Aster went back
to his team's coach because this was
that in Olympiad and consulted with his
coach and his coach total you know you
do what she wants and so yes or decline
the draw in the worst position and you
know there was a whole whole story there
by yes to cerimon if you want to hear
the full story you'll have to ask you
asked her for it but the long and short
of it is that yasser actually did manage
to battle back in a similar position so
i wanted to take a look at that game
which I'm claiming is from the testable
masters because it's a game of one of
the commentators from the Chesil masters
in reality this is I believe from the
nineteen eighty Olympiad but it's still
a fun game nonetheless to wrap up on we
had c4 c5 and a very similar line here
96 g3 and now d5 as we've seen a it
takes d5 d3 Bishop e7 Bishop g2 the
difference in this case is yester didn't
do any of this funny business with
delaying Knight f3 just sort of starting
with that move Bishop e6 now is in fact
getting a slightly different position
than before with this Bishop already
leaving the defense of the b7 pawn we
had castles castles a3 Queen d7 Bishop
up to D 2 and this is just very standard
stuff both at the time and still today
it would be pretty standard to see this
being played and now f6 and this is sort
of the setup that Yan declined to go for
in his game by leaving the bishop on c8
and playing this Queen d7 to d8 move and
perhaps in hindsight maybe this setup
would have been a little bit simpler to
to go for in fact the move rook c1 came
on the board for yessir very similar
stuff to what we see Fabi doing in the
game that we just analyzed rook FD 8 now
by McHale tall and now the move before
it does come on the board and so this is
perhaps an advantage for white that we
did not see
in the Fabi game yeah sir does in fact
get this before moved through whereas on
the other hand black has managed to kind
of complete his development a little bit
more thoroughly than we saw Yan be able
to do now in the game
the knight takes c3 Bishop takes c3 and
Bishop d5 came on the board and this is
quite nasty stuff actually by towel sort
of the whole point of whites play is to
kind of establish a monster Bishop on
the g2 Square staring down the long open
diagonal and with Bishop d5 tall is very
much saying yes you have failed do that
I will contest this Bishop and you will
get nothing for your efforts now in this
game I mentioned this idea of d4 and
fabi's game and mentioned that it was
sort of a big mistake for Fabi in that
case however in this game I think it
would have been a slightly different
story there is really one very
particular instance where the movie 4 is
playable for white in this in these
cases and that instance is when you can
immediately follow it up with the move
d4 and this is one of those cases
so if Eve or Bishop back to f7 or for
example the move b5 the movement ip8
we're not actually gonna take the time
to defend this pawn instead we are very
much going to play the move d4 and this
is perhaps something that Yassir could
have considered maybe he did consider
obviously there's a lot of reasons not
to go for it you sort of leave your
entire queen side on priest but in
general if you can get both efore and d4
in it is going to be very advantageous
for white for example he takes d4 and
Knight takes d4 and already you're
eyeing some very key squares such as the
f5 square also eyeing ideas like 'if
I've for yourself opening this Bishop
opening this bishop with some really
crazy stuff to follow now in this game
though yes we just plays the move Queen
c2 not ready to go in for this efore
craziness and now the move a5 does come
by tall sort of forcing the asters hand
to play the move b5 now rather than a
silly move like 9p8 which what in fact
just allow a much better
of this efore business tall of course
plays the move Knight to Knight to d4
and now after Bishop takes d4 he takes
d4 this is definitely a case where the
movie 4 is no longer going to be an
option for for Yaser here quite simply
in this pawn on a three hanging espanha
b5 is hanging this pawn on d3 might end
up hanging too much to to deal with for
Yasir so he plays the move Queen B - and
now tall simply plays the move
c6 we had B takes c6 B takes c6 and now
a four by yes sir
and this is as the aster himself said
just a good position for black tall has
the two bishops he has the extra central
space with this d4 pawn and he's doing
quite well here in in my opinion in the
game he chose the move c5 which is very
sensible solidifying this d4 pawn yes er
continued with the move Queen c2 we had
to Rick a b8 seizing the open file
tonight back to d2 for yes sir
and now Bishop back to e6 for tall and
perhaps this is the case where tall was
playing for a bit too much maybe he
should have actually just captured on
the g2 Square and gone in for something
like rook before with just a very
pleasant position instead though he does
keep these bishops on the board which
perhaps he may live to regret yeah sir
now continues very simply with her it
could be one contesting the open file
but Hall does manage to keep the open
file with the move rook before and now
yes sir plays a very very sad move and
that said move his rook takes before
allowing C takes b4 with a protected
passed pawn for for black now what did
he get in exchange for it well he gets
the open file and this is this is a
great way of playing before Yassir here
because he's actually in a slight
disadvantage in this game so he traded
sort of just an objectively bad position
for a position where yeah white our
black definitely has a really nice pawn
on b4 and this is going to me
Kalai very difficult for whites and in
fact black is probably doing better than
white in this case but white has
something for it right he's got
something he's got a file at the very
least and in fact the game quickly
turned in the Astor's favor after the
slightly nonchalant move Queen to d6
this is in fact just not a very good
move and by tall now Queen B 2 is the
Astra's choice revealing this rook and
after rook c8 rook takes c8 it should
take c8 Knight be three all of a sudden
all of your pawns mr. Tao are hanging
and what are you going to be able to do
about it
it's not so clear you tried the move
Queen e5 to defense both Queen takes d4
is playable immediately but yes or even
went as far as to play the move f4 first
now after f4 Queen III check King f1 g5
was tiles choice and being tau you're
facing towel yes there was probably a
little bit concerned after the move g5
came on the board but it turns out this
move is not quite as severe as tile
probably had had hoped
in fact the move Knight takes a5 does
just come on the board and all of a
sudden it's Yassir playing for the win
so this is how you can sort of turn
games into your favor if you have a
position that is kind of sort of just
bad for nothing right your opponent is
just better in sort of every aspect it
can be really useful to give your
opponent a definite advantage in one
area so long as you get a little bit of
something in return right in this case
Yassir gave tile the extra excellent b4
pawn but in return he did actually get
active along this C file and that's what
ended up turning the game in his favor
so sometimes it's better to give up a
lot for a little than to give up a
little for nothing right because then
you have something to play for it's
something to look forward to in your
position and that's what yessir does
here now Bishop e6 and I didn't - c6 and
already things are just collapsing for
me hail towel Bishop c5 was played in
the game now Knight takes b4 GF for
night
into d5 it's Queen and pawn bishop takes
d5 takes d5 King g7 Queen b7 check
Bishop back to e7 Bishop efore hitting
this bishop so King f8 Queen c8 check
King g7 Queen g4 check King f8 and
somehow a sir has corralled this pawn
now rather than capture on f4 answered
chooses to take on age 7 allowing the
move Bishop d6 which is still fine G
takes f for Bishop takes F for king up
to g2 and there's no checks for tall
Bishop d6 Bishop back to e4 Queen d2
what's his choice and now Yasser starts
his big push to victory Bishop e5 h5
king e7 and Bishop back to f3 for a
little bit of safety king d6 Queen g6
now to support the Aged pawn even
further and now after Queen f4 we do
just see the move h6 and yes it has a
very fun game now of
ring-around-the-rosie that he plays with
his king queen h2 is check this King
drops to f1 now if the move Bishop g3
and the idea for yester is to take on f6
and play Bishop g2 defending against the
checkmate
so not Bishop g3 but rather Queen h3 is
check Bishop g2 Queen c8 is threatening
a perpetual so King f2 we can see one
and now Bishop back to f3 and the
ring-around-the-rosie it has sort of
been completed Queen III check King g2
Queen f4 and believe it or not it's this
position except it's the other side to
move after Queen at 4 so an excellent
game of ring-around-the-rosy yes or a
professional ring-around-the-rosie
player I do believe and he does manage
to gain a tempo for his pursuits age 7
now and now we niche to check King 8th
one Queen h3 check Bishop g2 Queen c8
king of two Queen c1 bishop f3 the ring
around the rosy has been completed again
and tall simply resigns he could have
gone to moose further
it's allowed white to Queen in the
perfect scenario but rather than do that
he did just resign this game so an
excellent game by Yasir that I thought
deserved to be highlighted as well with
a slight connection to the chest full
Masters Tournament hopefully you guys
enjoyed these games here today that is
it for the road to 2000 up next we are
going to move on to some end games from
the chasuble Masters Tournament in the
end game class so stick around for that
move on over I think it's a different
link for you guys watching life other
than that my name is Caleb Denby thank
you so much for watching and I will see
you next time
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]